I think that I can relate to your
cynicism about corporations and
basically just not expecting them to be
the drivers of doing the right thing and
and the the Milton Friedman piece is
very elegant and but he talks about you
know how corporations are basically
maximize profits within the constraints
set by law and governments and you kind
of talk about well you know it's really
about governments imposing rules and in
on corporations but the problem is that
it's not one way you know you have huge
corporate influence in policy and just
to pick on one of your competitors is
payer you know Exxon Mobil you know
spending until recently vast sums of
money trying to combate the science and
climate change and you know trying to
you know influence policy and so I think
that's where kind of in practice the
sort of an argument falls short you
can't rely on governments because
there's so much corporate influence in
state governments and so you know
whether you like it or not it seems that
there is you know if you want to achieve
kind of the most social utility you do
somehow need that morality in
corporations so and I'm just curious
when you when you talk about wanting to
initiate these principles put values in
place how do you think of yourself as
leading the industry how do you think of
yourself is wanting to attacked those
groups to come along to the same change
the reason I asked this summer I worked
in sustainability business developer
Ford Motor Company and I worked directly
under the gentleman who wrote their
human rights charter and this is
something that was a first of its kind
in the industry and one that all of the
other producers came around to across
developing world to ensure there were
standards of production and and labor
rights and labor labor treatment how do
you perceive that and what are you
trying to do with the things you're
implementing for your own company to
impact the community of companies that
you interact with and compete against
I don't get to hear the answer before I
ask well I I originally might was gonna
be a defense of what I think this Tim
was saying if it's or my understanding
of the Milton Friedman which is that
because we care so much about social
issues corporations are not a vehicle
that can ever effectively address them
it's it's not what they're set up for
and it not only that it also works
against their their missions which have
nothing to do with social benefiting
social society and in general I have a
pretty sober notion of what the Human
Rights Council can achieve or does but
it seems like from my understanding of
the delaying out these pillars something
that would be in line with the friedman
is just clarifying all the confusion
around it since you do get bogged down
with possible lawsuits and with and it
certainly is not the intention to abuse
and disrespect human rights of the
corporations I'm sure they would just as
soon respect them
both morally and because it's better for
your bottom line if you don't get
employees leaving and if you don't get a
bad rap and so that seems valuable in a
way that doesn't expect corporations to
know you know to have human to have this
moral mission which they don't
that would be clarifying which seems
like a let me say clearly I just don't
think it's realistic to just the
structure and it's a longer argument the
structure and I think Friedman did it
really Joan
with the structure of corporations and
where they're lodged and what they have
in terms of status doesn't make it
meaningful to hold them responsible I
hold you responsible and you're sitting
there worrying about you know companies
lobbying you should have been in Florida
you know getting out to vote for you
know Obama who took five hundred our you
know maybe the answer is not we have bad
government and guys go and lobby for bad
things that the answer is not they have
some mythical hope that this legal
fiction is gonna all of a sudden have
moral standing though the answer is they
have a good government and have you know
campaign finance laws and disclosure and
all the things about that that mean you
can't be you know fifteen lobbyists from
the state of Michigan going to lobby to
flush our taxpayer money is not a rat
hole to make up for bad management for
the last 25 years who fought cafe
standards tooth and nail and would have
not only made the environment better but
would have actually been more
competitive businesses you know which
the you know Honda's and the Toyotas the
world have demonstrates so the answer is
not to come up with this fairy tale that
corporations all of a sudden have this
this this soul and that they you can
hold them accountable the answer is
let's get good government or let's
boycott night night year let's all go I
went with with the John Corzine of rich
old Brook to Darfur to take pictures and
to come back and we'll and Corzine you
know proposed a genocide amendment so
that you got a focus on where you
actually can make a difference in where
there is some framework for me
yeah and I mean I agree and when I am
when I'm focused on is I don't want
companies to hurt people anymore and I
want to figure out how to make them stop
doing that
and I I don't I agree I don't think that
companies need I don't think that
companies have an inherent
responsibility to engage on some of the
world's biggest problems some of them
want to do that that's I think that's
great and I think it makes sense for a
lot of companies in a lot of industries
I don't think they have a responsibility
to do that I think their
responsibilities is to do no harm so
that's that's focused on here and part
of the point of setting out these
distinct pillars it is to define
responsibilities to define these
responsibilities as distinct from each
other so to say absolutely governments
have a duty to protect and and that's
non turaga and they have to fulfill this
duty but also corporations have a
responsibility to respect so if they're
operating in a conflict zone if they're
operating a place where government has
just collapsed or is in or post-conflict
and and can't possibly be expected to
function the way it's intended that
doesn't mean that it's a law free zone
so companies still have a responsibility
to respect human rights regardless of
what the state is doing so that that's
the point of defining those pillars as
distinct from one another because the
problem with that draft that I have
mentioned and a lot of the rhetoric that
you hear is that governments have a
primary duty for human rights and and
and then that draft played on that to
say okay well companies have a kind of
secondary responsibility which kind of
makes it sound like okay governments are
supposed to do everything and then
companies can kind of take whatever is
left over and you can see the kind of
strategic gaming that this could lead to
particularly for example in places like
where I was in Indonesia or in Darfur
where the government says okay cool the
more I step back the more everyone wants
companies to move in and that is
completely inappropriate right so the
point is to define those
responsibilities as obviously they're
related but as distinct from one another
the the the point about working within
industry groups is an interesting one
and I think it's it's been quite
different of in terms of climate change
and in terms of the environment so I
mean when when when Lord Brown took this
very big bold stance of stepping out of
the industry group and being the first
head of a major energy company to you
know proclaim that climate change was an
issue and we were gonna do something
about it he was not a popular guy that
you know the big industry dinners but
that I think felt quite different to to
human rights and so one of the keys
seminal moments on human rights is in
the late 90s where BP after the
nationalization of lots of country's oil
industries and VP was kicked out of
Bolivia and kicked out of Iran it was
really a US UK company and going into
Colombia in the 90s those kind of its
first re-entry into the rest of the
world and BP got into a lot of trouble
cuz if you take a guy who spent his
whole career in Scotland and send them
into Colombia and say just build the
same you know piece of kit and you'll be
fine we got into trouble for allegedly
supporting a violent paramilitary group
to help protect her projects and this
was right around the same time in Ken
Sara was assassinated in Nigeria and a
lot of people say that shell could have
been should have done more at that point
that's when companies sort of said you
know together like there's no framework
what are we supposed to do I don't know
how we're supposed to interact with
security forces and with host
governments so at that point the
industry came together to come up with a
framework working within
right swatch in the US and UK
government's came up with something
called the voluntary principles on
security and human rights and this is a
voluntary set of principles but it's
become the de-facto industry standard
for how companies interact with their
security forces so I think there's been
a realization on human rights that this
is a non-competitive issue that it moves
everybody to act together and then in
the Cadbury's case is another good
example of saying actually it will be
more effective if we act together than
if we act alone